how about the perfect murder i've
thought sometimes about the perfect
murder
you know what you do you pick up one
person by the ankles
and you beat another person to death
with him
and they both die and there's no murder
[Applause]
weapons
what happened here sergeant looks like a
pedestrian accident to me
they must have been moving at quite a
clip
the baton rouge one was especially
annoying to me because in
baton rouge cop shoots an unarmed black
guy
then week or so later black guy
in response kills three cops
randomly not all
murder is senseless that was
senseless and it was random you're in
baton rouge it's not a big town
you could have killed the cop
that killed the unarmed black guy
they said his name on the news and you
know where he works
how little legwork are you willing to
put into your murders
where you go kill three random cops and
ah
[ __ ] riots and then blue lives versus
black lives where if you kill the actual
cop responsible the entire country would
just go
well that worked itself out
we need more murders that unite
people no more
divisive murdering you're a lazy
murderer
and that bothers me
i mean what am i capable of
i'd like to think that i'm a nice person
but i don't know man
a lot of it is context
there's a lot of things i wonder if the
world was different like if murder was
legal
i might have killed a few people i don't
know
i'd love to think oh i would never do
that but we really need the law against
murder
for one simple reason the law against
murder
is the number one thing preventing
murder
we'd like to think it's because like oh
i would never do that no it's because it
really sucks getting caught murdering
a lot murder was
legal or just a misdemeanor
like you get a thing in the mail oh [ __ ]
they had a camera there
if murder was legal there would be so
much murder
regular people would murder murderers
would murder even more
and then really nice sweet people would
murder a few people
but nobody would murder no people
you wouldn't trust somebody who didn't
murder if murder was legal you wouldn't
like them
i never killed anybody okay nice meeting
you
what a creep i mean not even a hooker
live a life what's wrong with that guy
he's like a mormon or some [ __ ] i hate
those guys
i think he's nice shut up janet it would
just
if murder was legal there would be a lot
of murder
children would behave very differently
because
mostly parents would be murdering their
own kids that's mostly what would happen
if murder was legal you'd be you know
you go to a mall there'd be like eight
different moms in the mall just i told
you to stop
it you didn't listen to me just
your beaches you'd be stepping over dead
kids it'd be like a new problem
you have to clean up your kids when you
kill them because it's gross
it's bad for the environment
if you murder your child in a public
place please use one of the red bags
that are in the dispensers every three
feet of america
put your murder child in the red bag
with a logo of a
murdered kid on it next to the other
logo that tells you not to
let your alive kid play with a plastic
bag
because they might suffocate
in which case you could just leave them
in the bag
that is a whole bunch of horrible
thoughts right in a row
right in a row do you know i've been to
my mum and dads i was talking to my mom
about stuff
all right and she was saying now um
this flower uh solved
a crime what happened was
there was a murder right in an office
so they said it's obvious that someone
who works in the office did this murder
because that person's only a
sort of a typist he has you know they've
done nothing wrong
so they said that's narrowed it down
right so this flower man came in
and he said i can sort this out for you
so he said what do you mean
he said well during the murder
the plant was knocked off the cabinet
right right um and he had some special
wires that he can put some
wires on the flower and it starts
shaking and stuff
because even though you can't see it
flowers pick up bad vibes and whatever
if you shake a plant
it doesn't like it okay so what happened
was
uh he said right what we'll do we'll put
the plant back on the shelf
yep we'll water it we'll calm it down
then get
get a nice cup of tea then get every
member of staff right to come in the
room yeah and just
go near the flower right so don't tell
that so like a line-up for the flower
kind of like a lion don't tell them what
we're doing just send them in and say
stand by that cabinet where the murder
what happened
yeah anyway it was a long day they were
getting through a lot of stuff it was a
big office block
yeah yeah um they were going this isn't
working you know flowers not budging
suddenly they get into like the last
part of the day when they were almost
giving up they call in a sketch artist
the pla the plant gives them a
some some caretaker fella um
yeah said go over there was it was it an
old man that i mean
because scooby doo didn't like him from
the beginning so uh
you know is that that why is that
janitor so
evil the they send the caretaker over to
the planet he's going
you know he's thinking i've got away
with this of course plant
starts shaking what have you they did
him okay wait a minute then
so was there any other evidence was that
the only evidence they used in the trial
well no it's one of them things though
imagine if you're that caretaker and you
think i've got away with this then
suddenly a plant grasses you up you
weren't expecting that
so suddenly you're off guard and you go
you go
okay okay okay come get that
chrysanthemum away from me i did it
you're talking absolute bollocks that
was one of the most nonsense pieces of
[ __ ] i've ever heard
in my life it didn't happen okay norm
you're a canadian
yes i am so what do you think of this
whole presidential mess
uh well i hope that uh uh the democrats
don't steal the election from the
uh the winner you know but who knows
you like george bush i love george bush
man he's a good man
decent you know none of this
yeah he's uh you know he's not a a lie
or a crook murderer or anything like
that so
it'd be good to get the see i i don't i
think we should get the
homicide out of the white house and get
like a
a fresh start because we don't want any
more murderers i think we should just go
on to the next question
how about the murderous yeah oh clinton
he murdered a guy yeah you know
you're not awesome but i have no
accusations with that that's a little
too that's the way it does let's just
let's just go on to the next book yeah
this is not my week what can i tell you
oh it's not mine either and i'm being
very nice okay
i'll be a good boy now norm do you never
hear
[Music]
and i don't want to hear it and this is
not the place to make those accusations
and you're supposed to be funny
there you go this is a live show
let me do this okay i'll tell you what's
a matter of record you will not be
invited back if you don't shut up all
right
[Applause]
let's talk football all right
manslaughter
did you ever hear the word oh the phone
hello oh yeah
oh no uh the thing is this there uh you
know matt
strauss yeah the producer the producer
he told me it would be funny
he said like why don't you carry a cell
phone on and then let it ring and then
pretend like there's a guy on it is
there anybody on it no
it's a thing pretending you know what
norm
you're a dead man
here you're talking to a man you know
what barbara you know what you said
about
rage
[Laughter]
not only have you annoyed us
[Laughter]
that you have you have actually annoyed
one of your idols who is that
oh the great bill cosby yeah what'd you
do oh my god i love that guy he's my
hero you know just like you maybe joe
or uh bill clinton would be your hero i
i love
i love there's no stopping you isn't it
no you seem to like bill clinton and
this man leads into our show
on friday night i know so right his
career is over after this anyway who
cares
go ahead norman no bill clinton who's a
great man obviously
you know everybody has their opinions
right mm-hmm are you moving along
bill cosby is a great man first of all
there has never been
any accusations towards bill cosby about
anything you just tell us what you did
bill cosby
oh i i met him i i opened for him at a
club
and he was a great man you know he's my
hero of all time you know how funny bill
cosby yeah so get to the point
i'm going past menopause